Evet Herkese merhabalar
ülkemizin 100 akı gençlerinden biri olan
sevgili kadircan'dan sonra sahnede olmak
benim için çok keyifli Ben de hem
yazılımcı fabrikasından hem de üretken
akademi'de Mümkün Mertebe destek olmaya
çalışıyorum Her zaman da gerçekten
Akdeniz bir isimdir ve sahnesinde de
ağırladığımız bir arkadaşımızı böyle
gençlerimize ihtiyacımız var yine genç
olarak adlandırdığımız ve her zaman da
gençlerimizi İnançla Aslında yola
çıktığımız bir noktada yine gençlerin
organize ettiği bir tedx organizasyonu
içerisindeyiz Ben de bir tedx
organizatör olarak aynı zamanda ulusal
kitapta birçok etkinliği organize etmiş
bir hem konuşmacı hem organizatör hem de
aslında işin Bilişim tarafında yer alan
birisi olarak bugünkü etkinliğiyle çok
başarılı buldum Öncelikle emeği geçen
her bir gencimize o yüreklere
ağızlarında şu an büyük bir coşkuyla
burayı izliyorlar Onlara büyük bir alkış
rica edeceğim emeklerine sağlık çünkü
TED kültürü der ki Paylaşmaya değer
fikirlerinizi Dünyanın her yerinde
etkisi olan etkisi olmayan ve fark
yaratmış insanlarla bir araya getirin
Deniz hocanın sunumu tam manasıyla bir
Evet yani tedin yapmaya çalıştığı şey
aslında bu benim de şimdi anlatacağım
şey dizayning biraz bu Kadir Cihan
yapmaya çalıştığı Halim Hoca'nın
anlatmaya çalıştığı şeyler hepimizin
Paylaşmaya değer hikayelerimizi
fikirlerimiz var dertli insanların
sahnesi bu kırmızı nokta ben de bu
dertli insanları bir araya getirip
sürekli o insanlarla bu güzel parlak
gözleri bir araya getiren bir insanım
ama benim de hayatımın temel noktası
Aslında birazcık tasarımla başladı
tasarımda değişti Ben de biraz sizlere
Dizayn Things Anlatmaya çalışacağım ben
Emrah Kozan uzun yıllar sektörde adolfte
Apple tarafında Sertifikayı treni olarak
görev almış bir Bilişim uzmanı aynı
zamanda bir sürü Eğitmen yetiştirmiş bir
hibrit Bilişim bir insanıyım kendim bu
şekilde adlandırıyorum ama benim
hayatımı değiştiren şey biraz pandemi
oldu pandemiden Sonra ben 10-15.000 saat
web grafik tasarım dersi anlatmış
sürekli projeler yapmış arayıp yapmış
bir insan olarak Dizayn thinking’in
neden Türkçe kaynakla anlatılmadığı
derdini düşmüş Bir adamdım ve Antalya'da
yaşadığım için de pandemi bizim için
biraz daha cennette Aslında doğanın
içerisindeyiz ve bu tasarım odaklı
düşünce
Ercan Altuğ Yılmaz'ın gazıyla başlayarak
yaparsın abi Hadi Abi dediği noktada
kitabı yazmaya başladım Bir yıl boyunca
bu kitabı yazdım bitirdim tamamladım
akabinde 10 üniversitede kaynak kitabı
olarak kullanılmaya başladı hala
alanında ilk ve tek Türkçe kaynak ve
dizaynik noktasında Anadolu'nun birçok
yerine ben ücretsiz destek vererek bu
farkındalığı yaratmaya çalıştım benim
için çok müthiş bir sosyal sorumluluk
projesiydi bir şarkı blog yazarıyım
üzerine teknik yazılar yazıyorum Aynı
zamanda O ne diyor yazayım o neydi o
tarafında da tasarımcı kafasında
tasarımcı gözünden gündelik olaylara ve
Aslında problemlere Hatta tarafının
hayatın birçok noktasına değindiğini
anlatmaya çalışıyorum hem bu konu
anlamları ufak bir mikro yazarlığım var
diyebilirim Bugün bir hikaye anlatmaya
başlayacağım size aslında
insanın kendi hikayesiyle başlayacak
gerçekten hepimizin de kendi içerisinde
bir yolculuğunda Binlerce yıl önceki
yolculuğumuzun birebir aynı olduğunu
göreceksiniz İnsanoğlu yeryüzüne
keşfetmek için geliyor ve İnsanoğlu
yeryüzüne gelir gelmez yaptığı ilk şey
yaşadığı mağaraların duvarlarına bir
şeyler çizmek oluyor yani Düşünsenize
yeme içme barınma ihtiyacınızı
gideriyorsunuz hemen sonrasında
yaşadığınız mağaranın duvarına hayvanlar
çizmeye çiçekler böcekler çizmeye
başlıyorsunuz neden
bakın tasarım insanoğlunun yeryüzüne
geliri icat ettiği ikinci şey
antropolojik bir vakadan bahsediyorum
ben iddia ediyorum bakın bir arayüz
tasarım için ekran tasarlıyorum
130014 bin sene önce yaşayan insanın
bir duvara bakışı Neyse bugün dijital
ekranlara bakan insanların bakışı aynı
tasarım O dönemlerde bizim içgüdüsel
olarak aslında geliştirdiğimiz bir
metodolojiydi Çünkü tasarımla Biz
problemleri çözmeye başladık 13.000 sene
önceki atalarımız tasarım sayesinde
yerdeki bir taşı o an silah olarak
kullandı evine götürdü bir eşyayı yontu
götürdü bir biblo olarak kullandı ve ona
vermiş olduğu duygusal biçimsel bir
hikaye Neyse tasarım o şekilde bize
aslında bütün eşyaları bütün nesneleri
Bütün hayatı yaşamı
şekillendirme ve biçimlendirme
anlamlandırma şansı tuttu tasarım bir
keşif yolculuğudur ve tasarım süreci de
insanın çevresinde keşfettiği bir
problemi bir ihtiyacı herhangi bir
konuyu çeşitli yöntemlerle çözme
sanatıdır İnsanoğlu yeryüzüne keşfetmek
için gelmiştir ve tasarımda onun en
güçlü silahıdır beyinin beğenmeyin
ekranda gördüğünüz görsel bir problemi
çözer bir ihtiyacı giderir insan oğlu
yeryüzünü keşfetmek için gelmiştir ve bu
keşiflerle hayatta kalmıştır değil mi
Bir tasarım dediğimiz şey bir çözümdür
bir üretimdir bir nihai fikirdir İlla
şekil biçim renk mizanpaj tipografi
değil Sevgili dostlar Hepimiz bir
tasarımımız hepimiz tasarımcıyız
Sabahları uyanıyoruz aynanın karşısında
kendimiz o gün için tasarlıyoruz değil
mi teteks sahnesine çıkacaksak ona göre
tasarlıyoruz Kadir cihanda olmuşuz siyah
kahverengi gidiyoruz
sevgilimizle görüşeceksek kendimizi o
güne göre tasarlıyoruz değil mi yataktan
kalktığımız gibi bir iş görüşmesine
gidemiyoruz ya da yataktan kalktığımız
gibi sevgilimizde görüşmeye gitmiyoruz
kendimizin de aslında biçimini Tasarımın
ayna karşısında yapıyoruz tasarım
antropolojik bir vakadır ve sadece Biçim
şekil mizanpaj tipografi değildir
tasarım dediğimiz şey ve problem çözme
sanatıdır aslında Peki problem ne bakın
problemi olan bakış açınızı
değiştirirseniz hayatınız değişiyor
problem Bence bir fırsattır İngiliz
Challenge diyor meydan okuma diyor Bir
fırsat bir avantaj bu şekilde bakarsanız
tasarım dediğimiz olguyu da aslında
değiştirmeye başlarsınız ve Steve
jobs'un dediği gibi tasarım bir şeyin
sadece nasıl göründüğü değildir aynı
zamanda nasıl çalıştığıdır çalışma
prensibidir çevremizi iş ortamımızı
yatak Odamızı değil mi çalışma masamızı
Her şeyimizi tasarımla değiştiriyoruz
yani renkler biçimler mizantaşın dışında
bir hikaye var ve Anadolu'nun içinde
yaşıyoruz Anadolu ki Bence Mesnevi Hatta
meyve yedik
Biz antin King King'in Belki de ilk
anlatıldığı nokta insan odaklılık
herkese kucak açma Derine empati değil
mi ve yaratıcı fikirler Kolektif çalışma
biçimi ve ne diyor Hazreti Mevlana gemi
neredeyse su oradadır problem neredeyse
sıkıntı neredeyse Deva oraya gider suyu
ara susuzluğu bul yani sıkıntıyı keşfet
deneyimle yaşa ve sonra bekle sular
alttan üstten fışkırsın bu Dizayn King
belli bir gün içerisinde var mı var
bakın daha da derin Hazreti Mevlana'nın
sözlerini araştırırsanız daha da derin
bugüne Kolektif çalışmaya problem
çözmeye insana odaklı yaklaşımlara çok
daha yaklaştığını görürsünüz biz sadece
kendimizden uzaklaşarak birazcık
ambalajla çok odaklandığımız için kendi
derin felsefemizi uzaklaştıkça derini
göremiyoruz Tabii ki bu biraz farklı
konularla yapılıyor Biz yeterince
kendimizi promot edemiyoruz ama birazcık
kendi içimize odaklandığımızda
problemlerin gene çözümünü kendi
içimizde bulunacağız Ben hep söylüyorum
Dünya bir Survivor parkur parkuruysa
Türkiye Bunun en Zorlu noktası en Zorlu
etabı geçmek çok zor hayatta kalmak bile
bizim için bir çok zor ve biz en küçük
problemlerimiz de en büyük
problemlerimizde tasarımcı bakış
açısıyla çok rahatlıkla çözebiliriz
Çünkü Donald Normalde der ki
Mühendisler ve iş insanları problem
çözmek için eğitilir ama tasarımcılar
henüz ortaya çıkmayan problemleri bile
çözebilirler ne demek bu bakın otomobil
mucidi Ford ne diyor insanlara Ne
istediklerini sorsaydım Benden daha
hızlı giden bir at arabası isterlerdi
diyor yani İnsanlar o an gerçekten neye
ihtiyacı olup olmadıklarını
bilemeyebilirler kullanıcının size
söyleyemediği ötesindeki ihtiyacı çözümü
bulduğunuzda inovasyon
geliştirebilirsiniz tasarım yapmak
tasarımcı ve düşünmek gerçek bir
inovasyon yaratmaktır işte işin ta
kendisidir Dolayısıyla iç görü dediğimiz
konuyu yakalamak için bir tık daha ileri
gitmemiz lazım günlük hayatta bir
tasarımcı ne yapar bir problem vardı bir
sıkıntı vardır otururuz bu problemi
anlamaya çalışırız Evet neymiş Sorun
neymiş problem değil mi bir tasarımcı
Bir sucuk firmasına da çalışır teknoloji
firmasına da çalışır döner Fethiye'deki
bir yat firmasına da çalışır
ketçabın kullanım süreci hepsi aslında
bir bütün ve tasarım bu kadar zor bir
şeydir işte bir kamera yapmak
istiyorsanız bu telefon yapmak
istiyorsanız önce kullanıcının insanın
buna sizden daha çok sarılması gerekiyor
önce insanı ikna edeceksiniz insanın
size Söylemediği ihtiyaçlarını
problemlerini anlayacaksınız İşte biz
bunu Aslında birazcık tasarımcı Gibi
Düşünmek diyoruz Benim harika bulduğum
müthiş bir adam var Twitter rams ve
deter rams 1950'li yıllarda ekranda
gördüğünüz radyoyu çizmiş sonra Steve
Jobs gelmiş değil mi yeni modern çağda
bir iPod yapmış o dönem açmak kapatma
tuşlarının çalışma prensibi tasarım
prensesi neredeyse aynı ve diğer adamsın
bir kitabı var çok zar zor buldum adamın
1950'lerde 1960'larda yaptığı tasarımlar
bugün yok
Gerçekten yok sadelik minimalizm estetik
ve çalışma prensibi işte çalışma
prensibi Tasarımın ta kendisidir Sevgili
dostlar ve ülkemizden bir örnek
kullanıcı anlayın insan için tasarlayın
diyorum ya Trabzon'da bir ATM makinesi
Trabzon'daki herkesin
akıllı teknoloji bir Yapay Zeka sistemi
var yani atm'lerden bugüne geldiğimizde
artık Yapay Zeka teknolojisi bizim için
çok daha uğraşacak bizi daha çok
anlamaya başlayacak ve insan odaklı
çözümlerin de bence Tepe noktası yapay
zekanın hayatımıza kullanılması olacak
chat gpd Belki çok duyuyorduk ama ilk
defa Belki de yapay zekanın Somut bir
örneği olarak karşımıza çıktı diyorduk
ya Bu sistemin arkasında Yapay Zeka var
doğru vardır inanıyorduk ama çek gpty
Bunu herkesin kullanabileceği bana bir
makale yazsın Bana bir içerik yaz bana
bir sunum yap dediğinizde bunu hayata
geçirmeye başladım makine insandan ilham
alarak insan için üretiyor bakın yine
içerisinde dizaynik ve insan odaklı
yaklaşım var peki tasarımcı olmak için
ne ihtiyaç var geleceği değiştirmek için
Yarını inşa etmek için hatta sunumun
başlığı Yarın tasarlamak için
ihtiyacımız olan şey yaratıcı özgüven ve
biz mağaralardan yaratıcı Özgüven
Yürüyoruz sevgili arkadaşlar İlker
insanlar bizden daha kreatif Daha
yaratıcı özgüvene doğuyor ama eğitim
işte yaşadığımız sosyal ekonomik
sebepler bizi çok ciddi şekilde negatif
ediyor ve yaratıcı Özgüven dediğimiz şey
ne Aslında çocuk gibi düşünmek değil mi
Paulo Cola'nın harika bir sözü var
Yetişkin bir insanın bir çocuktan
öğrenebileceği 3 şey var bakın çok
kıymetli bu lütfen çocuk gibi düşünün
Hatta zaman zaman kendinize işte Deniz
hocamın bir saati gibi 5 dakika verin
bir çocuk gibi hayatımda Ben neyi
başardım ve çocuk gibi nasıl hangi
aşamalar çocuk gibi düşünebiliyorum bunu
yaparsanız gerçek anlamda bir şeylerin
değiştiğini görürsünüz Yoksa her gün işe
git eve gel işe git eve gel maşallah
dediğimizde o Yaşam bizim için bir
farkındalık bir farklılık yaratmıyor
yaratıcı Özgüven bizim sihirli gücümüz
hepimizin içinde bulunan sihirli güç
yani Hepimiz birer süpermensek bunu
yaratıcı Özgüven sayesinde
mağaralarımızdaki atalarımızdan
aldığımız sayesinde başarıyoruz ve
yaratıcı Özgüven sayesinde tasarımla
dünyayı değiştirebilir Yarını
tasarlayabiliriz yarının Dünyası ancak
yaratıcı özgüvenle inşa edilebilir ve
benim de hayatımı değiştiren şey Dizayn
King'in kitabı Olmuştu Ben de kendi
içinde yaratıcı özgüvenimi kullanarak Bu
kitabı yazdım acaba doğru mu yapıyorum
yanlış mı yapıyorum abi beni gömerler mi
Ya sen kimsin derler mi yıllardır
10-15.000 saat tasarım dersi anlatmış
yüzlerce arayüz projesi yapmış tasarımcı
gibi düşünmeyi hiç tasarımcı yazmamış
hep kişisel gelişim değil mi kurumsal
eğitimler Ya ben bir tasarımcıyım nasıl
düşüneceğimi biliyorum dediğimde inanın
oturup yazdığım 40 TL sayfa beni bu yola
itti yaratıcıya özgüveninizi
kullanmazsanız Bu kitabı yazamazsınız
sokağa çıkamazsınız sahneye çıkamazsınız
hepimizin yapabileceği çok kıymetli
işler var herkes birer Yıldız bu kırmızı
daire tedinde
olarak söylüyorum herkese açıktır herkes
burada bir şey anlatılabilir Hepimizin
bir hikayesi var ya Bence bugünden sonra
ben o kırmızı dairede Neyi
anlatabilirimi de cebinize Lütfen koy
Çünkü bu sahne bunun için var ve tedin
kuralıdır kesinlikle ünlü ya da ünlü
olmaya çalışan Pier insanların sahneye
çıkarmayın bakın buradaki bütün gün bu
tede harika hikayeler dinlediniz ve
hepsi Kıyıda köşede kalmış ve gerçekten
şimdiye kadar hiç duymadığınız hikayeler
İşte bu TED kültürünü yaşatmanın da
birazcık benim misyonumda amacımda bu o
açıdan tekrardan Tebrik ederim
şey işte budur aşamalı bir problem çözme
metodu benim peşinde koştuğum Evet işte
buldum dediğim şey buydu Tam benim
içindi çünkü ben bir bilgisayar
öğretmeni olarak Kemer Koleji'nde
çalışmaya başladığımda ilk dizaynak
duyduğumda Allah Allah dedim böyle bir
şey mi varmış ne bu diye araştırdığımda
standfort'u gezdim stand Fort diyor ki
biz Hani tinking bu
bir problem olur bir problemi
empati kurarsınız insanlarla problemi
tanımlarsınız fikir üretirsiniz portal
hep yaparsınız ve sonra bunu test
edersiniz ama bu bana yakın bir şey
değildi yani benim cümlelerimde benim
kelimelerimle anlatılabilmiş bir şey
değildi Ben sonra bunu kendi
eğitimlerimde kullandığım Bunu ilk defa
bir sahnede kullanıyorum çünkü kendi
eğitimlerinde Ben böyle anlatmaya
çalıştım dedim ki Emrah Hisset bir
problem var hisse tabi Tamam hissettim
gözümsedim sonra keşfet çık Problem ne
nerede ortaya çıkmış gerçekten Buradan
mı oradan mı keşfettim Şimdi akıl et
Antalya'nın en iyi Golf sahalarını bir
hafta Golf oynadım Ondan sonra bir Golf
aplikasyonu yazmanın bir Golf
aplikasyonu neden kullanıldığını Anladım
arkadaşlar tasarım odaklı düşünce ile
sektör bağımsız her konuya çözüm
üretebilirsiniz size bunu vaat eder
hangi işi yaparsanız yapın yaratıcı
özgüveninizi kullanarak küçücük
masanızdaki bir problemi de dizaynikle
çözebilirsiniz Toplumun en üst
noktasındaki kaotik problemleri de
çözebilirsiniz deprem problemini çözmek
için Dizayn thinke ihtiyaç var empatiye
ihtiyaç var göçük altında kalan İnsanla
aynı empatiyi kurarsanız o göçüğün
altından çıkmak için elinizden gelen her
şeyi yaparsınız ülkemizde en çok
ihtiyacımız olan şey bu Buradan da bütün
depremzedelerimize geçmiş olsun diyorum
ülkemizin başı sağ olsun ama daha çok
Kollektif çalışmaya daha çok meydana
gibi düşünmeye ve tasarım odaklı
düşünmeye Bence ihtiyacımız var ve son
örnekten bahsedeyim dünyada değişmiş çok
fazla nokta var ve Nepal'de bebeklerin
ölümünü
metodolojiden bahsediyorum Nepal'de
Bebekler doğduğunda ilk 30 saat
içerisinde hastane yetiştirilemediği
için hipotermiden yaşamlarını
kaybediyorlar ve bunun için oturuyor
Amerika'da bir firma çocuklar için
bebekler için bir Hipotermi geliştiren
bir çanta üretiyor ve bu çanta sayesinde
ne halde bebek ölümleri %90 üzerinde
azalıyor bakın dünyayı değiştirmek
istiyoruz değil mi Dünyanın üzerine bir
fark yaratmak istiyorum size bunu
sağlıyor lütfen öğrenin Ne olur öğrenin
dünyayı değiştirmek için ihtiyacımız
olan şey gerçekten Bence Dizayn King'in
ve bunun için bizim başka bir şeye
ihtiyacımız yok zaten muhtaç olduğumuz
Kudret damarlarımızdaki
Teşekkürler Benden bu kadar
[Müzik]